[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيه بودكاست وانا
راويه العلمي
تعودنا في عائلتنا الصغيره انه نخصص يوم
في الاسبوع بنخرج جميعا للغداء في مكان
جميل هذا المكان لازم يكون خالي من
الاجهزه الذكيه والتلفزيون واي شيء يمكن
يشتت الانتباه المهم احد اهم تقاليد هذا
اليوم هو الحديث عن وجهه النظر الشخصيه او
الرؤيه اذا صح التعبير لكل شخص منا يعني
لكل فرد من افراد العائله بخصوص اي موضوع
ما ممكن يكون هذا الموضوع من المدرسه او
من الحياه من الاخبار او حتى مواقف ومشاعر
وذكريات ما بدي اطول عليكم بس من كم اسبوع
موضوع حديثنا العائله كان ذكريات
وانطباعات الطفوله
اللي توقفت عنده بصراحه هو الانطباعات
المختلفه تماما في بعض المواضع اللي
بيحملها ابني وبنتي اللي بتصغره باربع
سنوات كلن على حده عني انا وعن والدهم
وكانه كل واحد فيهم عاش مع ام واب مختلفين
وبالتالي ذكريات كل واحد فيهم عن مواقف او
مرحله معينه من طفولتهم اختلفت بشكل كبير
في مشاعرها وتفاصيلها
كمان مثلا بيذكر اني كنت العب معاك كتير
وكنا نبني مجسمات من الليغو بشكل يومي
وكنا نتنزه ونروح اماكن جديده دائما بينما
ليلى بتذكر كتير اشياء بس يمكن ابرزها اني
كنت دائما مشغوله وهذا يمكن شي منطقي بسبب
انتقالي من قسم الاخبار في قناه العربيه
وليلى كانت ما زالت رضيعه
الحقيقه بعيدا عن انزعاجي وشعوري بالذنب
بسبب الانطباع اللي تحدثت عنه ليلى الا
اني حبيت اني افهم اكثر على الصعيد الشخصي
فرحت ابحث عن الجذور العلميه او عن الجواب
العلمي لسؤال كان كل ما يخطر ببالي واحنا
عائدين للمنزل في ذلك اليوم
لماذا اخوان يحملان نفس الجينات يتربيان
في نفس البيت بنفس الثقافه ونفس المبادئ
ومع نفس الام والاب بيطلعوا مختلفين تماما
وكانهم تربوا مع اب وام مختلفين
الهدف ما كان اعداد حلقه لبرنامج كلام
منطقي ابدا لكن ما وجدت الحقيقه مهم وبفسر
كثير من الظواهر اللي بيعتمد عليها علم
النفس الحديث هذا عدا عن انه الشواهد عليه
مبهره التجلي في حياتنا وتفاعلاتنا
اليوميه في اكثر محيطاتنا الفه ومع اقرب
الاقربين فحبيت اشارككم ما وجدت
مبدئيا الموضوع مرتبط بتفاصيل كثيره البعض
منها جيني بحث والاخر نفسي ومش بس مرتبط
بالعوامل النفسيه المحيطه بالطفل وهو عم
يكبر بل بتلك المحيطه بابويه ايضا
لكن قبل ما ندخل في التفاصيل اعزائي
اسمحوا لي ارحب بضيفي من عمان الدكتور
عاطف القاسم رئيس جمعيه العلوم النفسيه
العالميه اهلا وسهلا فيك دكتور معنا في
كلام منطقي اهلا وسهلا استاذ راويه مرحبا
اهلين حبيت ابلش معك بسؤال عام الحقيقه عن
هذا الموضوع الشيق هل بنقدر نقول بانه
الصفه الغالبه او السمه الغالبه على
الاشقاء عاده بكون الاختلاف اكثر منه
التشابه هو في الحقيقه يعني كل انسان
مختلف عن الانسان الاخر يعني مهما كانت
درجه القرابه ودرجه التطابق في حتى في
الدوائم المتطابقه الا انه الصفه العامه
لكل انسان اللي هو متفرد في كل شيء يعني
هناك بصمه نفسيه لكل شخصيه انسانيه مع
وجود بعض التشابه طبعا في الحالات اللي
يكون فيها اشقاء او توائم
متطابقه بيكون في تشابه كبير جدا بس هذا
لا يعني التطابق في الشخصيه يعني هناك
مساحه من الاختلاف يعني علينا كتربويين
وكاسر ان ننتبه الى هذا الاختلاف ونستغله
في سبيل تنميه القدرات الخاصه بكل طفل على
حده او التعامل مع المشكلات السلوكيه
المرتبطه بهذا الاختلاف بطريقه مختلفه
من طفل الى طفل اخر يعني هو الحقيقه
اللافت كتير في هذا الموضوع قديش العامل
الجيني
مع العامل البيئي باثروا تقريبا بالتساوي
او حتى ربما الاعتقاد كان سائد زمان بانه
هو العمل البيئي اللي له تاثير الاكبر
يعني طلع خاطئ لانه على ما يبدو حتى
الجينات يمكن يوصل تاثيرها لاكثر من 60%
على صفاتنا النفسيه بس على كل حال احنا
بدنا نناقش هذا الموضوع من منطلق نفسي
يسمح لي اكمل شرح لاعزائي المتابعين
ومتابع الحديث
اختلاف الاخوه هو موضوع لم تخلو منه الكتب
السماويه او التاريخ او حتى الاساطير
والقصص الشعبيه
ابتداء بقصه قابيل وهابيل الوارده في
الاديان السماويه وقصه النبي يوسف واخوته
وصولا لمسرحيات شيكسبير ولدراما
والتلفزيون وانتهاء بحياتنا الواقعيه وهذا
الاختلاف كثيرا ما يتطور في هذه الامثله
لتنافس شديد تداعيات غيرت مجرى التاريخ في
كثير من الاوقات
فبحسب تعريف ويكيبيديا للتنافس ما بين
الاخوه فهو نوع من المنافسه والعداوه بين
الاخوه سواء كان على صله قرابه بالدم ام
لا حيث يقضي الاشقاء وقتا مع بعضهم البعض
اثناء الطفوله اكثر مما يقضونه مع
الوالدين
غالبا ما يكون الارتباط الاخوي معقدا
ويتاثر بعوامل مثل معامله الابوين ترتيب
الميلاد الشخصيه والخبرات والاشخاص الذين
يتعرضون لهم خارج العائله يكون التنافس ما
بين الاخوه الشديد بحسب ويكيبيديا خاصه
عندما يكون الاطفال متقاربين جدا في العمر
ومن نفس الجنس او عندما يكون احد الاولاد
او كلاهما موهوبا فكريا
ورغم انه التنافس ما بين الاخوه هو شكل من
اشكال هذا الاختلاف الا انه مش بالضروره
ابدا يكون نتيجه حتميه له بل في كتير من
الاحيان بياخذ هذا الاختلاف شكل ادوار
مختلفه بيلعبها الاشقاء وبتحركها صفات
ومزايا مكتسبه من بعض العوامل الخارجه عن
ايدينا مثل ترتيبنا مثلا في السلم العائلي
وهذا بالفعل ما ركزت عليه الدكتوره جيني
براون في احد فصول كتابها غروير سلف اب
جاني هي مؤسسه ومديره مؤسسه انظمه العائله
والها عياده بنفس الاسم والتخصص في سيدني
في استراليا حيث تدرب نخبه من الاختصاصيين
النفسيين ورجال الدين ورجال اعمال بارزين
الدكتوره جاني تشير في كتابها الى انه كل
منا وكانه يكبر في عائله مختلفه ومع اب
وام مختلفين عن اشقائنا رغم ترعرعنا تحت
سقف واحد بتقول بانه هذا يعود الى تفاوت
درجه ونوعيه الاهتمام الذي ينال كل منا من
ابويه يعني من نفس الاب والام فالبعض منا
بنال درجه متوازنه من الاهتمام والمساعده
بالمقارنه مع احتياجاتنا المنطقيه بينما
يحصل البعض الاخر منا على اهتمام مبالغ
فيه ايجابيا كان ام سلبيا
ودرجه الاهتمام اللي بنحصل عليها بتتفاوت
بحسب عوامل كثيره متعلقه بالوالدين
وبالاطفال كمان ومنها الترتيب اللي بنحتله
في العائله وفي عده نقاط يمكن لازم ذكرها
بهاي النقطه تحديدا بانه لما بنحكي عن
الموروثنا الجيني موروثنا الجيني باثر
علينا مش بس بصفاتنا الشكليه او فيما
يتعلق بشكلنا الخارجي او حتى الامراض اللي
احنا ممكن نكون عرضه للاصابه فيها وما الى
ذلك ولكن حتى صفاتنا النفسيه نتوارثها
ايضا عن طريق الجينات النقطه الثانيه
بعتقد اللي مهمه جدا هون بانه يعني يمكن
هي صفاتنا الجينيه هي اللي بتحدد كيف رح
نتفاعل مع محيطنا او شو راح يكون رده
فعلنا لاتجاه هذا المحيط اللي ممكن تكون
هاي رده الفعل مختلفه تماما عن رده فعل
شخص اخر وهنا بيجي يمكن صلب حديثنا اللي
هو البيئه تاثير البيئي لما نحكي عن
الاطفال يمكن ابرز او اهم عامل بيئي هو
الاهل الام والاب وهذا الشيء اللافت بشكل
كبير دور الام والاب او طريقه تعامل الام
والاب والاهتمام اللي بيعطوه لاطفالهم في
مراحل عمريه مختلفه يمكن هو كلمه السر في
هذا الموضوع مثلا شو يعني شو شو بيتكلم
العلم او على الاقل الدراسات اللي انعملت
عن
العلم الجيني السلوكي خلينا نقول او
الوراثي السلوكي فيما يتعلق بالابن الاكبر
بكون في له شخصيه او دور معين بالعائله
مختلف عن دور الاخرين
هذا بياكد الكلام اللي حضرتك فضلت فيه انه
للوالدين تاثير كبير جدا يعني لكن يعني
تاثيرات
الوراثه والتاثيرات الجينات بتكون
بالسنوات الاولى استاذ رايه ثم تاتي جهود
الوالدين لتقديم جرعه من
المهارات الاجتماعيه هو المعرفيه فيبدا
الطفل يبدا الطفل بالتغير طبعا بالنسبه
للطفل الاكبر يعني الطفل الا اولا هو يعني
امل الوالدين في مرحله الشباب يعني بنعرف
كلنا انه الشاب والصبيه لما بيتزوجوا
بيكون في عندهم رغبه في انهم يكون عندهم
طفل ويشبعوا هذه الحاجه الى الامور
والطفوله لذلك ما فيش تجارب سابقه فشخصيه
هذا الطفل الاكبر اولا هي يعني تجربه للاب
والام جديدين فار تجارب دائما الاطفال
اللي بيكونوا اكبر اخواتهم
يعني بدنا تجارب انا كنت في ادرس فار
تجارب اعترف بهذا الموضوع انا اكبر اخواتي
هو هو حقيقه يعني مختبر تجارب يعني للاباء
والامهات ولذلك يقع كثير من الاخطاء
السلوكيه احيانا يعني بيكون في اكثر ما
يميز الطفل او طريقه تعامل الاباء والامه
ات في حده في تمرير بعض
المبادئ والاخلاقيات وكذا يعني بدهم هذا
الطفل وكانه يعني مصمم بطريقه مثالي
تخيل زي ما هم بيتمنوا او ما بتحبوا ما
فيش ما بيكونش عندي الاباء والامهات اجداد
معامل مع اخفاء الطفل ولا في احتواءه يعني
لما بيغلط احيانا بيتعاملوا معه بحده ربما
يصرخوا عليها او يضربوه او يطالبوه باشياء
هو يعني ما زال غير قادر على انه يقوم
فيها يعني وانا شفت بعض
يعني اجاني مره اب وام صايبهم اكتئاب شوي
يعني بدهم يعني يدخلوا في كابه ليش لانه
الطفل بصف بعمر اربع سنوات لسه ما بيعرف
يكتب ويقرا
فاثناء انه هاي مرحله تعليم مهارات
اجتماعيه مش مطلوب من الطفل انه هو يقرا
ويكتب ويحفظ اناشيد ويحفظ زي ما احنا
متخيل باستمرار هذا غلط يعني هذه تربويه
لكن على الصعيد الاخر
الجانب الايجابي من الموضوع الطفل الاول
ربما يكون لديه شخصيه قياديه اكثر من باقي
الاخوان لانه هو يتنمذج مع الاب والام
يعني احنا بنشوف الصغار بقلبه الوسط او
بقلده الكبير لكن الطفل الاول ما فيه
اخوان او او اخواتي يقلدهم فبمين بتنام
بصير مع الاب والام فبكون سلوكه اقرب لا
سلوك الكبار يعني ممكن انه يصلح للقياده
فيما لو تم استغلاله هذا الموضوع بشكل
تربوي وموجه من الاباء والامهات
بينما الصغير في العائله بيكون دائما او
مش دائما يعني في معظم الاحيان بتعود على
انه يكون اتكالي في اناس اخرون دائما
بحلوا له مشاكله وبيعملوا له اي اشي هو
محتاجه
هو الطفل المدلل
واحيانا يعني بيكون الوالدين وصلوا مرحله
انه
يعني مرحله من من الملل في ما عاد عنده
قدره انه يفرض سيطرته او هي او الطريقه
اللي كان يفكر فيها زي اول طفل يعني كل
مال من هذا احيانا يترك هذا الطفل يعني في
مهب الريح يعني انه ممكن ما يتعرض لنمط
تنشئه متوازن هو بياخذ حنان زياده عن
اللزوم لكن ما باخدش بنفس الوقت ما في
خطوط حمراء او ما في توجيهات تربويه تعيده
الى خط التوازن الاوسط اللي المفروض انها
تنمو عليه الشخصيه يعني احنا البني ادمين
دائما يعني بنحب هيك ومنحبك يلزمنا يكون
في سلطه في حياتنا ويكون في حنان في
حياتنا لكن الدراسات الاخيره استاذ راويه
بتقول بانه التعلق اللي هو بين الصغير
اللي هو اصغر الابناء وبين الام بيكون
عالي جدا ولذلك بتظهر عند هذا الطفل
ضعف في مهاره اتخاذ القرار لاحقا
بده يعيش فتره الدلال اللي عاشها عند امه
او عاشتها عند امها مع شريك حياته ولذلك
ربما يعانوا هذول الصغار من بعض المشكلات
في العلاقه الزوجيه انه بعضهم يعني ينظر
للشريك العلاقه الزوجيه بانه بديل الاب او
بديل الام لا مش امك زوجتك الموضوع مختلف
فبيظهر عندهم بعض المشكلات في هذا الموضوع
طبعا احنا الكل استاذ راويه لانه في
السلوك البشري لا يمكن انك تقولي كل كل
البشر هيك يعني كل الصغار او بيطلع لك
دائما الناس شادين عن القاعده طبعا اكيد
اكيد انا الحقيقه كمان لفتني في معرض بحثي
نقطه مهمه جدا في يعني فيما يتعلق
بالترتيب في العائله وكيف باثر على
تصرف الاهل مع هذا الطفل وبالتالي كيف هذا
باثر على تطوره وعلى نموه وعلى صفاته حتى
النفسيه لفتني بانه حتى الاطفال مثلا
خلينا نقول الطفل الثاني اذا كان هو يعني
الطفل الاكبر منه كان مشكلجي او بيعمل
مشاكل كتير او او يعني بياخد كتير اهتمام
سلبي من اهله دائما ما يميل بكون هذا
الطفل الثاني الى المسالمه بيكون مسالم ما
بيحب يكون في بينه وبين اهله مواجهه
بيبتعد او بيتجنب اي اثاره اي مشاكل
بالنسبه لهم والعكس صحيح كمان اذا كان
العكس الطفل الاول هو المسؤول هو اللي
دائما ما بيعمل مشاكل وبساعد وكذا طفل
الثاني اللي بيكون مشاغب اكثر
اشرحلنا اكثر عن هاي النقطه دكتور وكيف
هذا باثر على الاهل لانه بتلاقي مثلا
الاهل بيقولوا انه احنا بنحب كل اطفالنا
بنفس الطريقه ولكن مثلا مش بيفضلوا ولكن
بيستسهلوا التعامل مع احد اطفالهم اكثر من
غيره
صحيح هو بالمطلق ما في طفل زي الثاني لكن
الطفل الثاني بعض الدراسات تشير بانه لديه
تفكير تاملي بمعنى ان الطفل الثاني يراقب
تعامل الوالدين مع الطفل الاول يراقب
سلوكات الطفل الاول ثم يتخذ موقف بناء
عليه طبعا هذا كيف يدعم بيظهر انه بيصير
في نوع من التفاعل الانتر اكشن بين
الموقف اللي عم بصير والطفل رقم اثنين عم
بشوفه عم بخزنه وبين قدرات الى الطفل
الثاني يعني انت فيك تميزي بهذا الجانب
بين الطفل الثاني اذا كان لديه ذكاء عالي
او اذا كان لديه ذكاء متوسط او ذكاء منخفض
لانه الموضوع يتفاعل مع
نسبه يعني بالعاده الذكاء العالي رقم
اثنين انا عم بحكي عن رقم اثنين اذا شفاء
من رقم واحد اللي هو اخوه الكبير وشاف كيف
الاهل بيعاملوه بيطلع باستنتاجات ذكيه
فممكن هو يعدل فبتلاقي الاهل ميالين او
مرتاحين يتعاملوا مع الطفل الثاني بيقول
لك يا اخي ركز هذه ما غلبناش زي اول واحد
لانه هو عم بيشوف لانه عنده قدرات عقليه
تخليه يعمل نوع من التمييز الاخطاء من
الاشياء الصحيحه فهو عم بتجنب عم بتجنب
لكن احيانا اذا ذكاء الطفل رقم اثنين كان
ذكاء متدني فهو عم بشوف الطفل الاول
بالنسبه له موديل فبصير عم بقلد ممكن يزيد
اكثر من الطفل الاول كمشاكل يعني او ممكن
يكون عنده نشاط زائد يعني غير متحكم فيه
فالمساله فيها راحت تفاعل مجموعه كبيره من
العوامل يعني كل حاله ممكن ندرسها كحاله
مستقله يعني عشان هيك احنا بننسخ الوالدين
باستمرار انه انهم يلجاوا الى مختص سلوكي
لتقييم الحاله ووضع يعني اطار للتفاعل او
التعامل مع هذا الطفل وتعديل سلوكه بشكل
علمي وعدم المقارنه ما بين الاطفال
الاطفالنا يعني لانه يعني هالم غير عادله
لعده اسباب منها انه كل شخص فينا مختلف
تماما عن الثاني وهعمل جينات مختلفه حتى
وانت شاركنا مع اشقائنا بخمسين في الميه
من جيناتنا ولكن السيكونس تبعها الترتيبها
ما بين الجينات المختلفه اللي لدينا
مختلفه تماما عن اشقائنا ولكن حتى في كثير
عوامل بتاثر علينا خرجه عن ارادتنا معنى
ذلك او احنا ما بنقدر نتحكم فيها باي شكل
من الاشكال ولا حتى اهلنا بيقدروا يتحكموا
فيها ومنها ترتيبنا بالعيله يعني اذا انا
طفل الاكبر رح ينحط علي مسؤوليه اكثر
بكثير بينما اذا انا الطفل رقم اثنين راح
يكون في عندي فرصه للتعلم ولتعديل
التصرفات والسلوك افضل او اكثر بكثير من
الطفل الاول فهذه كلها اشياء يعني للاسف
نحاسب عليها او نوصل بها بانه هذا الطفل
شخصيته كذا او كذا لاسباب خارجه عن
سيطرته وارادته تماما هو يعني اسوا ما
يمكن ان يفعله الاباء والامهات انه يتم
عمليه مقارنه بين الطفل وبين اي طفل اخر
يعني سواء كان شقيقه او ابن الجيران او
ابن خالته او ابن عمته او ابن عمه هذا
موضوع يعني ياما تحدثنا عنه انه يترك
استمرار اثر سلبي في ذات الطفل يعني انت
عم بتحط مقارنه غير عادله ما في طفل زي
الثاني من ناحيه القدرات ومن ناحيه
امكانات حتى لو اخوه حتى لو ذكائه متشابه
ما عندك يا اخوه الا انه طريقه تفاعل هذه
الفكره عنده كيف واللي بشوفه بالمدرسه
واللي بيسمعوا من زميله واللي تفكر فيه
بالليل مختلف تماما عن المفكر فيه
اخوه يعني فهذه المقارنه باستمرار يعني
بتعمل نوع من تدني تقدير الذات
في الارض انه انت عم تعطي حكم على شخص وعم
تصنع عدو لابنك يعني بحيث انه ينظر له
نظره عداء نظره عدائيه يعني
كثير من من يعني او مش كثير يعني بعض
الحالات وصلت في اطفال انتحروا بسبب هذه
المقارنه
تماما يعني انت احيانا ممكن تعمل نوع من
المقارنه الايجابيه تقول له يا الله انت
ذكي زي خالك او انت رائع زي فلان يعني تحط
له نموذج نفس الوقت انت عم تعطيه نوع من
التدعيم الذاتي للشخصيه بدون الانتقاد اما
موضوع انه ليش ابن خالتك ليش اخوك عمل هيك
وانت بتعمل يعني هذا موضوع نطلع منه يعني
للاباء حتى ما بين الاخوه لانهم يعني
العلاقه المفروض بتربط الاخوه تكون علاقه
مفعمه بالحب
شعور
بالانتماء لنفس العائله ولكن للاسف هاي
المقارنه ممكن يعني تزرع شعور عدواني ما
بين الاخوه وتنافس يعني في غير مكان
وخلينا نقول النقطه الثانيه اللي كنت حابه
احكي عنها دكتور هي موضوع انه تفاعل الاب
والام مع اطفالهم مش بس يعني يؤثر عليه
ترتيب الاطفال في العائله ولكن ايضا ترتيب
الام والاب في عائلاتهم ايضا الحقيقه يعني
او مش انصدمت ولكن تفاجات من هاي النقطه
لما كنت عم بعمل البحث بانه اذا كانت امي
او ابي اكبر اخوانها او او
اصغرهم او في المنتصف هذا كمان باثر
وبيغير طريقه تعاملها معي انا كطف كطفلتهم
من المؤكد ما هو الاب اللي كان مدلل ولما
صار قبل الان هو جاي
يعني مجموعه من الانماط السلوكيه من فتره
طفولته مراهقته جاي بده يعملها مع اولاده
فهو مؤكد انه باثر وعلى الابناء ايضا ان
يكونوا واعين بانه نمط شخصيه ابوك او امك
اللي كان يعني تعرف انه مثلا تربيتيم او
متربي مدلل او متربي تحت تاثير العنف
الاسري بالتالي هذه يعني كل انسان في عنده
مجموعه من عقد النقص اللي ممكن انها تظهر
لاحقا على التعامل مع اسرته مع ابناؤه
فاحنا كمان كابناء بدنا نكون واعيين على
طريقه تشكيل شخصيه ابانا امهاتنا لما
بنكبر شويه يعني احيانا بروح بعطي بعطي
محاضرات في المدارس وبتعرض لبعض الاسئله
من المراهقين بيكون في المرات لون من
المراهقين
على الاباء وعلى طريقه دائما
بنحملهم اخطائنا نوعا ما انه افهم ابوك
وامك لماذا يتصرف بهذه الطريقه يعني دائما
لما احنا بنفهم وجهه نظر الاخر بصير فيه
شوي هيك تسامحيه مع الاخطاء اللي عم
ترتكبها لكن هذا اكيد ربما يقود لاخطاء مع
الابناء طبعا هو يعني يقال بانه الانسان
يصل مرحله النضج عندما يستطيع ان يرى
والده ووالدته كبشر وليسوا كام واب
وبالتالي يقيمهم كبشر عاديين يخطئون
ويصيبون يشعرون
يسهون يعني يقال بانه وللاسف هذا النضوج
ما بنوصله واحنا في مرحله الطفوله لازم
نوصل يعني عمر معين او ربما تجربه حياتيه
معينه لغايه ما نوصل لهذا النضوج ونقدر
نشوف اهلنا بهاي الصوره
هو هذا صعب المنظور احكي لك ليش صعب يعني
قله من الناس من تصل لهذا
المستوى السامي لانه اولا ما يحكم العلاقه
بين الاباء والابناء هو العاطفي اكثر منها
العقل انت بتعرفي بالعاطفه
العاطفه السائده في هذه العلاقه هي عاطفه
الحب والانتماء فاحنا بسبب حبنا هذا
الهائل اللي ابانا وامهاتنا خلينا نحطهم
بدرجه ساميه احيانا من من يعني بنطلع فيهم
فوق بمستوى البشر ونعتقد انهم ملائكه مش
لازم يغلطوا فباللحمه ندرك فيها بحكمه انه
هم بالاخير بشروا يصيبونا ويخطئون
وبالتالي احنا بدنا نتعامل مع اخطائهم
بطريقه اعتياديه او بطريقه عاديه ونقبلها
ونتقبلها ويعني
ونحترم هذه الاخطاء وما نكون يعني احيانا
بصير في انتكاسه يعني كنت هذيك اليوم عم
بقرا عن فنانه عربيه ابنها سحر لما عرف
انه هي تمارس الرذيله يعني طريقه انه صب
يعني عدوانيته على ذاته بسبب الحب الهائل
طبعا بين الطفل او بين هذا المراهق وبين
امه يعني لا نتقبل انه احنا نتعامل معهم
من منظور معرفي التعامل من منظور
بهذه طريقه تدريب ربما او تنبيه لاحقا
ما فيما يتعلق بالعامل الجيني فالمعروف
انه اي طفل يرث 50% من جيناته او حمض نووي
الدي ان ايه من احد ابويه و50% من الجانب
الاخر و50% من الاخر
لكن هاي الجينات وترتيبها ومركباتها
ومعادلاتها ممكن تختلف كثيرا من طفل
لشقيقه تخيلوها وكانها اله يانصيب تحتوي
على نفس الارقام لكن النتائج ترتيبها
دائما بكون مختلف عند كل سحب
واللي ما بنتوقعه ابدا انه الارقام اللي
بتم خلطها في داخل هاي الاله ما هي الا
جينات الجد والجده على كلا الجانبين كون
انه جينات كل من الابوين هي خليط بنسبه
50% من جينات ابويهم اصلا وهذا الخلط
واعاده الخلط في كل مره هو ربما ما يفسر
التباينات والاختلافات اللي بتظهر في
نتائج فحص الدي ان ايه اللي بيقوم فيها
اشقاء
اما بالنسبه لكيف بتتحول هاي الشفرات
الجينيه لصفات وسمات وطباع فالدراسات
الحديثه اجمعت على انه الامر اعقد من مكان
يعتقد سابقا فمعظم الصفات اللي احنا
بنتحلى فيها متعدده الجينات يعني بتنتجها
مجموعه من الجينات بتعمل معا مثلا لون
العيون تخيلوا بيحددوا خليط من 16 جين
معظم صفاتنا المتعلقه بالشخصيه ما بترتبط
بجين واحد فقط فلا يوجد جين معين مثلا
لصفه القياديه او للامانه او للميل
للاجرام او العنف بل على ما يبدو حتى
نظرتنا للحياه ودرجه تفاؤلنا وقدرتنا على
التحكم بمشاعرنا والمحافظه على الهدوء تحت
الضغط يؤثر عليها مجموعه من الجينات
بترتيب معين اي اختلاف في هذا الترتيب
سيؤدي الى تغيير هذه الصفات
هذا طبعا ناهيك عن عامل اخر اكتشف حديثا
او بدا يظهر اثره واضح في عالم الجينات
وهو
الابيجنتكس او علم التخلق وهو علم دراسه
تاثير عوامل مثل الغذاء والتلوث البيئي
والضغط النفسي على كيف بتتجلى هاي الجينات
وكيف تترجم لصفات اوسمات وايضا قدرتها على
تغيير هذا التجلي
فعلى ما يبدو وبعد عقود من الجدال حول ما
هو الاهم او الاكثر تاثيرا عن تربيه
الاطفال الطبيعه ام البيئه يبدو ان هذا
السؤال سيحال للتقاعد مع ازدياد الادله
اللي بتشير الى انه الطبيعه والبيئه
يعملان معا لرسم ملامح اطفالنا وتطورهم
خليني ارجعلك دكتور من النقطه اللي توقفنا
حديثنا او توقف حديثنا عندها اللي هي فكره
انه البيئه مع الجينات لهم وقع هائل على
كيف احنا بنتطور وكيف بنطلع في النهايه
المنتوج النهائي من الناحيه النفسيه
تحديدا يعني انا الحقيقه من واقع بحثي
اكتشفت بانه الاعتقاد كان سائد ربما ربما
في العقود السابقه بانه العامل البيئي هو
الاهم ولكن الدراسات الحديثه عم توجد بانه
بلاش نقول انه العامل الجيني اهم ولكن له
وقع ربما اكبر بكثير مما كان يعتقد سابقا
هو الحقيقه شوفي موضوع الجينات وموضوع
الوراثه والبيئه موضوع جدلي لكن ما يقره
العلم بانه
المحددات الوراثيه تلعب دور كبير جدا في
تطور الطفل في تطور الانسان عموما يعني
اذا لدينا الاستعداد الوراثي فهذا معناه
انه هناك حد معين سوف تتوقف لديه القدرات
عن التطور وعن اكتساب
معا انا اشبهك بانه كانه احنا نعرف عن
اباتنا قطعه مطاطيه هذا القطعه المطاطيه
ربما البيئه تعمل على شدها وعلى استطالتها
وعلى انها تكبر وتنمو وربما تعمل على
انكماش هذه القطعه الموروثه فتتدنى
القدرات يعني في المحصل النهائيه لو احنا
بدنا نستسلم بانه الجينات فقط هي اللي
بتلعب الدور الرئيسي معنى ذلك بانه التدخل
التربوي والتنشئه الاجتماعيه ما راح يكون
الها اثر كبير وهذا في الواقع يعني مختلف
عن هذا نعم يعني
اعدادات الوراثيه تلعب دور في الحد من
الوصول الى قمه الابداع او قمه النمو
التفاوري لكن التدخل التربوي المناسب ممكن
انه يعمل على اثراء هذه هذا الموروث من
القدرات
وعلى اتساعه
استغلاله بصوره
اكبر اذن احنا واشقائنا بنختلف جينيا بقدر
ما بنتشابه لكن ماذا عن البيئه اليست
البيئه واحده على ما يبدو الاجابه الصحيحه
على هذا السؤال هي لا ايضا
بتقول الدكتوره جابور ميت في مقطع شهير
راج وقتها على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بتقول لا يتشارك اي شقيقين بنفس الابوين
لان هذين الابوين كان بمراحل مختلفه من
حياتهم عندما ولد كل طفل من اطفالهم وكان
لكل منهما تفاعل مختلف مع كل طفل اذا
بتتذكروا في حلقه سابقه تحدثنا عن
التصنيفات العلميه لانواع الشخصيات وخذنا
باسهاب في نموذج الشخصيات ذو العوامل
الخمسه وهي الاجتهاد والضمير الحي اللطف
والتمتع بالقبول الانفتاح او الانطواء
العصبيه او الاصابه بامراض عصبيه
هذه ربما ابرز نماذج الشخصيات اللي
بيعتمدها طب النفسي وفي فتره السبعينات
لما كان الاعتقاد العلمي السائد انه
المؤثر الاكبر على شخصيه الانسان هي
العوامل البيئيه تم اجراء العديد من
الدراسات حول التوائم المتطابقه اللي
تربوا في كنف عائلات مختلفه ومنفصله وبينت
نتائج هاي الدراسات انه العوامل الجينيه
بتتحكم وبتشكل ما بين 40 لستين في الميه
من الصفات اللي بتندرج تحت واحده من
الخانات الخمسه المذكوره سابقا يعني العمل
الجيني ممكن يكون الاكبر في تحديد شخصيتنا
لكن الدراسات والعلم ذهب ابعد من ذلك مع
اجراء دراسات حول تاثير هذا العمل الجيني
اللي بساهم في تشكيل الشخصيه على تفاعل
الاطفال مع ابائهم والنتائج توصلت الى انه
هاي العوامل الجينيه بتجعل كل طفل يتفاعل
بطريقه مختلفه تماما مع الطريقه
بتم التعامل فيها معهم من قبل الاهل وهذا
الحقيقه مجال قائم بحد ذاته ويسمى علم
الوراثه السلوكيه او
بهيفيكس ودراسات في هذا المجال في العقود
الاخيره اثبتت انه البيولوجيا لها تاثير
كبير على خصالنا النفسيه اما فيما يتعلق
بالتاثير البيئي فربما العامل الابرز هو
تعامل الاب والام مع كل طفل والاهم في ذلك
هو انه احنا انفسنا كاباء وامهات نتغير
عبر السنين ومنمر بمراحل حياتيه مختلفه
وضغوطات حياتيه متنوعه بتجعل تعاملنا مع
كل طفل من ابنائنا مختلف تماما ايضا برضه
يعني كتير مثير للاهتمام هذا الوصف بانه
كل طفل
يخلق او يولد في عائله معينه له ام واب
مختلفين عن اشقائه وكانه ربي مع ام واب
مختلفين ومع انه طبعا هم ربوا يعني مجموعه
اشقاء ريبيو في نفس البيت مع نفس الام
والاب ولكن الام والاب طبعا في مراحل
حياتهم المختلفه بتغيروا كمان وهاي نقطه
مهمه جدا لانه هن بشر ايضا وهاي رحله
حياتهم اكيد هو هو
نقطتين النقطه الاولى انه نمط شخصيه الاب
والام لما بيكونوا بالعشرينات وعندهم طفل
مختلف عن نمط الاب والام لما بيكونوا مثلا
الاب الخمسين والام بالاربعين وع
بسبب هذا النضوج الطريقه تتغير بالاضافه
دكتور مش عم نحكي عن هالفرق الهائل يعني
حتى مثلا اول طفل بيكون الانسان ما عنده
مسؤوليات كتير خلينا نقول هذا طفله الاول
ضغوطات الحياه ممكن الظروف العمل تختلف مع
الطفل الثاني اللي بيجي بعد كم سنه فقط
يعني مش بعديها بعشره او 15 سنه فبالتالي
بكون الشخص نفسه حتى بيتعاطى ممكن ما عنده
وقت اكثر هذا الكلام الحقيقه من تجربه
شخصيه لانه يعني مع ابني الفرق بين ابني
وبنتي اربع سنوات مع ابني كان في عندي
متسع من الوقت اكثر اعطيته اهتمام ومن
وقتي اكثر بكثير من بنتي لانه ظروف عملي
تغيرت لما جبت بنتي فهذا شيء كمان عامل
كثير مهم
اللي بيخلينا بالفعل يمكن ذكرياتنا
وانطباعنا عن اهالينا تختلف تماما عن
انطباعات وذكريات اخواتنا عنهم في نقطه
ثانيه يا استاذ راويه انه هلا شوفي احيانا
احيانا وانا بدي احكي كلام مهم جدا على
الاباء ان ينت
انه موقف واحد كفيل انه يعمل منعطف خطير
في شخصيه الطفل موقف واحد يعني هلا انا
ممكن كاب اكون في هذا اليوم مروح من شغلي
معصب او مختلف مع مديري او عندي قضيه مع
زوجتي ويجي التفريغ الانفعالي يتم انه انا
صرخت على ابني او ضربته ابني الثاني مش
موجوده هلا موقف واحد كفيل بانه يعمل هذا
الشرخ في الشخصيه او في العلاقه الابويه
فلا يمكن انك تقولي حتى لو نفس الاب والام
انه في نمط يعني موحد مع جميع الابناء
يعني احيانا احنا بنعرف يعني بعض المواقف
ممكن تؤدي الى
تشوهات احيانا او ان الطفل يفقد حياته او
يفقد عينه او فهذا هذا يمكن اخوه ما مر
بهذا الموقف يعني لذلك لا يمكن انك استنتج
انه والله اذا كانوا الاطفال بينتموا لنفس
الاب والام معنى نفس المعامل حتى يعني في
نوع من التمييز
العاطفي بين الابناء نفسهم يعني احيانا
بيكون مثلا الاب بده ولد ايجا بنت بده
اج
ا جميل بدها ولد حلو اجاها ولد مثلا نظرها
انه هذا الولد مش حلو لونها لونه شكله
ملامحه اذا الطفل في اعاقه او ما في اع
اقه بيكون نفس الاب والام لا يفصح
تحيزات الانفعاليه فبيغير طريقته
من طفل ما بيكون في ما بيكون في اتساق
بطريقه
الطعام وهذا يعني بخلينا ناكد على اهميه
فعلا انه الاباء الام والاب لازم يكونوا
منتبهين ومدركين كيف ظروف حياتهم الشخصيه
ظروف عملهم او مزاجهم باثر على اطفالهم
وعلى كيف اطفالهم راح يطلعوا وكيف راح
يتطوروا وكيف راح يكبروا بشكرك جزيل الشكر
دكتور
عاطف على هاي المشاركه معنا في كلام منطقي
وان شاء الله مشاركات ولقاءات مستقبليه
في ختام حلقتنا
طبعا المنطق بقول انه احنا كبشر بنتغير
وبنتطور بنمر بتغيرات في رحله حياتنا وهذه
سنه الحياه لكن الكثير منا ما بيدركوا
تماما هو تاثير هذا التغير او حتى تاثير
ضغوطات حياتنا الشخصيه على من حولنا خصوصا
على من تتعلق مصائرهم ومستقبلهم فينا اي
اولادنا
ففي نهايه لكل شخص منا تجربته الخاصه في
هذه الحياه وهذا المشوار الخاص لكل منا
بيبدا منذ لحظه الولاده حرفيا ومن واجبنا
كاهل احتضان هذا الاختلاف بين اطفالنا
واعطائهم الفرصه ليكونوا هم ليكونوا ذاتهم
الاصليه مع بعض التوجيه من قبلنا ومع
الكثير الكثير من الحب
هذا كلام منطقي على العربي يبغوت كاست
وانا راويه العلمي اشكركم ودمتم دائما
بامان باذن الله
[موسيقى]